and that
I just sprout first okay raisins
and then it has raisins in there and
then the seasonings are the fridge
chocolate french dark chocolate
coriander an especially ground cloves
cinnamon and that's the one I'm serving
tomorrow for the weenies bill for tea so
to Cheney Alfredo yeah
and this is like okay that is like oh my
god yeah yes okay
that is like so easy it's for garlic's
only two cups of catches tablespoon of
salt actually a little less than that
and about a half a teaspoon to 3/4 of a
teaspoon of nutmeg and Worcester you
puree that then the noodles are out of
the long squash and then the
intermediate part you know the inside
part where's the all the seeds which has
the high protein and that squash is then
taken and pureed into the sauces the
thickener and it comes perfect
Wow and this is like the salsa and so
yeah and so I did you know what your
needs are for tomorrow I'm happy to
whack whatever you want when I make a
killer borscht your beats for our love
these
these are super high endurance runner
who's staying with me and anyways I'm
gonna encourage her to like run with you
guys tomorrow I've not met her and I was
she's not allergic to beads or something
I'll be serving a wonderful washer you
all of this stuff when I make my own
potatoes the potatoes are made with long
squash the insides of the long squash
and cashews you have no idea like we ate
like takeout Thai food last night when
I'm finished
we were just it was one o'clock in the
morning and you know so you you have no
idea how grateful we are to have this
but it's one that makes you feel good
yeah yeah and the coconut butter the
true coconut butter olive oil garlic mix
yeah great so it's just like butter
butter but it's not better mm-hmm
no Kalibak Road open it up you gotta put
your finger in there that one is avocado
chocolate mousse made with rajul dates
coconut butter French chocolate and here
from our own backyard is macadamia nut
whipped cream
me you know from our own
backyard is that not wonderful oh my god
it tastes like like butterscotch caramel
yeah and so what you do is you serve
that up and then you put that that's
what I made you for dessert tonight yeah
I'll think about it but I think probably
I could turn out I do a fabulous panel
on instant pumpkin pie Wow
just like you know high carb like I'm
storing our glycogen with carbs and then
good you know yeah good clean the other
thing that I've got which I was gonna
offer to you guys is I have I don't know
if you've heard of lifewave patches hmm
the Olympics guys wear them I mean you
can see them underneath their shirts of
the basketball team and the whole thing
okay I have the pain patches but you put
this on the point the occupation points
and I had the booklet laid out to give
you and I go yeah we're driving down the
road I said okay I forgot the pain
patches no it's like that we're good
yeah right now it's to sleep and food
you know yeah we're gonna be good we
feel good I should have brought you
carnosine patches you sleep my dog and
it really talks about you
I had to worry about it you've gone far
and beyond anything he would have ever
imagined so so this is quite a gift
that's fine for me because I got to do
the women still then I've got huh Oh get
it to you because you can you can warm
up that in warm up suit you almost the
suit and the Coral Cove taters separate
okay now I do it is take the pan put it
on high because you're gonna have to pay
attention and then stir it till you put
your finger in it's like bathwater stop
that's 110 okay and so you're gonna stir
your potatoes like that and you're gonna
steer the beet borscht like that and
then the pie is served cold with pumpkin
cream sauce on top it's delicious it's
really that has that walnut and date you
jewel date crust and then well
everything's delicious I mean that your
agency tomorrow she'll be with us for a
fair Harbach a day on
yeah so yeah you know what I would
really appreciate let me give you my
cell phone number and what I'm doing the
woman's build with John if I kind of
know where you are when you're doing the
run part of it and that's why I'm saying
if that's gonna be the last thing and
that's going to be the latest thing I
think that our new roommate here with a
number yeah but no but this is the that
you don't have to sell the land